speaking of police it's spreading from
portland
i almost would say like a virus plane
clothes
police officers threw a protester
into an unmarked van in new york city
yesterday
the video is being widely shared on
social media
millions and millions upon millions of
views and once again we get to this
question of
what is the line between legal policing
by undercover officers
with undercover cars versus the
authoritarian suppression of protesters
appearing to be denied due process now
the police department
says this is a simple arrest a woman was
allegedly damaging police cameras
police came in arrested her open and
shut
it's all very very simple now it is true
that nypd will often use unmarked
vehicles when they're looking for people
with warrants the idea is
you want to show up in something that's
not obviously a police car if you have a
dangerous suspected criminal they may
act erratically or try to flee if they
see a police car so you show up with
some kind of unmarked vehicle now
the counter in this particular case from
legal advocates and from other groups is
that
this is the worst possible time to be
using these unmarked vans and that this
was not someone police had been looking
for for a long time who had prior
warrants
this was something that supposedly
happened during these
protests alleged damage to police
cameras and thus
using these unmarked warrant squad vans
is completely out of scope unless you're
trying to send a message
and intimidate now there are about four
five different issues here the first
issue
is the growing use of these squads that
drive up to a protest
guys run out with guns and throw someone
into the van
you may not even know whether these are
police or whether you're being kidnapped
and then they drive away
extremely dystopian extremely disturbing
and concerning
there's the bigger discussion about
reforming police we had a number of
segments about that
this week already we had another one 10
minutes ago and we're going to continue
talking about that
then there's the political utility of
the repression of protests for donald
trump and we can't ignore that
and we can discuss these things
separately nypd policy
federal troops versus local law
enforcement we can have all these
discussions separately but
under underneath all of this there's
this idea that a desperate cornered
trump
wants to foment chaos incite more
incidents to then justify
more deployment of militarized troops to
create more chaos
and more unrest to justify needing
an authoritarian president to protect
you from the chaos that you yourself
caused and fomented
there's this vicious circle feedback
loop and while here we're talking about
nypd rather than
federal paramilitaries that have been
dispatched the strategic implications
and the implications
politically are are very very similar
but there's another issue that we have
to talk about
one of the things that's coming up in
these incidents with unmarked vans
is people resisting arrest now resisting
arrest is an
old trope i've been telling you for
years that resisting arrest can be
a very pernicious catch-all that's used
to justify using more force against
people
to retroactively justify police
interactions where
it doesn't even make sense because you
can only start to resist arrest
after an an interaction has started
using resisting arrest as a
justification after the fact doesn't
make any sense but it's
extra relevant right now there are many
normal reasonable people who if you're
at a protest and an unmarked police
vehicle drives up
i'm already using the wrong terms you
don't know that it's a police vehicle
if a vehicle dries up that has no
indication of being a police vehicle
and dudes without law enforcement
uniforms
jump out and go after you you don't yet
have any reason to believe that that's
the police
you could genuinely think you're about
to be kidnapped by random people
so then you try to get away or at least
delay being taken
until you can figure out what's going on
now you're resisting arrest
and that's used to justify being
manhandled and even more force used
against you
it's a joke i mean it's it's truly a
dystopian joke
the people defending this or at least
looking the other way and saying
well it sort of kind of makes sense if
the woman was suspected of destroying
cameras
you've lost the plot how does it become
the norm
that this is how you're taken away for
the alleged crime
of damaging a camera okay
this is not some major violent
individual even allegedly
it's not someone uh wanted for beating
their wife
or what you know whatever imagine
whatever violent crime you want to met
you know raping someone
you're suspected of damaging
a camera and we're now saying it's an
acceptable response
for an unmarked van to drive up as if
they're looking for
whoever slam on its brakes
six guys run out and throw you into the
van
now i hope it doesn't happen but imagine
that if one of these out of uniform
officers
in an unmarked van gets killed because
someone believes they're getting
kidnapped
then what well then it will become a
catalyst
for even more repression of protests you
can be sure of that
but this is very ugly for four
five six different reasons and because
it is so
useful politically this you know even
though these weren't federal troops
this still serves trump's political
motivation
which is we're for law and order he
keeps tweeting every 12 hours trump
tweets law and order
it still foments the idea that we need
uh armed and aggressive police to keep
order in cities and it's useful for
donald trump either way so
let me know what you think is my
analysis missing something important
here
am i overstating the concerning nature
of this let me know i'm on twitter
and remember that you can get the daily
audio podcast
every day weekdays we take weekends off
on whatever
your favorite podcast platform is itunes
stitcher spotify pandora
you choose but we are on all of them and
we'll take a quick break and be back
after this
let me tell you real quick about one of
our sponsors cuts
clothing they offer super quality men's
t-shirts and they're giving you
15 off when you go to davidpakman.com
cuts that's c c-u-t-s because
solid color t-shirts are a really
important staple
in pretty much every guy's wardrobe i
think it's really important not to
overlook the value of having t-shirts
you love wearing
t-shirts from cuts clothing have been a
game changer for me and as a company all
they deal with
are men's solid color t-shirts so they
actually put a ton of thought
into the comfort the style the
durability of the t-shirts they make
they fit perfectly they're not scratchy
they don't shrink they don't fade they
don't stretch out over time like so many
other t-shirts they're really the most
comfortable t-shirts i've owned
and they look great this right here that
i'm wearing
on youtube is the split hem
crew neck t-shirt very soft
fits me perfectly it's the ideal length
go take a look at what they offer and
once you have it
you are really going to see and feel the
difference
their slogan is it's the only shirt
worth wearing
you will see why and you'll get 15 off
when you do it
by going to davidpakman.com cuts
that's davidpakman.com c-u-t-s